the nominees for outstanding achievement
in cinematography will be presented
tonight by a by a blight spirit and a
free spirit would you welcome Blythe
Danner and Steve Martin
good evening ladies and gentlemen and
happy birthday dad before we before we
present this award Steve Martin has been
asked to tell you in his own inimitable
style about cinematography well many
people who don't live in Hollywood or
work in the movies may not understand
what it is exactly that the
cinematographer does well let's examine
the word cinema meaning film or movies
an tog refer
the nominees for outstanding achievement
in tog Rafi are Nestor almond rose for
the Blue Lagoon
Ralph debo de for Coal Miner's Daughter
James crab for the formula
and Michael Chapman for Raging Bull
Jeffrey Unsworth and aji Lane cloquet
for tests winners are Jeffrey Unsworth
and geese me
except no one was
we'll be Jackie Unsworth
I know that my father would be so proud
to receive this award on his behalf or I
can do it thank you I would like to
express my gratitude to the Academy
members and thanks Claude very Columba
picture and all the crew we shall miss
Japan's war tonight I would say also I
won't say how much grateful to Roman
Polanski cinematography is a rather like
course he needs okay to win and Roman
Polanski was a wonderful writer for all
of us thank you